burr burr is author of beer and circus
how big-time college sports is crippling
undergraduate education he sat down for
this book notes interview in 2000
it's an hour mary Sperber author a beer
and circus where'd you get that name
well there's a line in Latin literature
the poetry vinyl said that Roman
emperors to distract the populace from
their policies gave them cheap daily
bread and now the Circus Maximus and
about ten years ago I was driving in
Bloomington on a Saturday morning it was
a football Saturday and happened to go
by the stadium and the parking lots were
filled with tailgaters and Sancho's with
my wife but across the road there are
these student apartment complexes and
there were beer kegs on lawns and many
students drunk already and such and my
wife who went to very different schools
she went to Berkeley said what's going
on here and I said it's beer and circus
and this was something that I thought
about a lot from my own undergraduate
experiences at Purdue where I had
freshman English in a class of 15 taught
by a full faculty member and faculty
were very accessible I now was teaching
it in a class of a hundred and fifty
students so I couldn't begin to teach
them to read and write at the level that
I was taught at a very similar
University to Indiana and I worried
about the decline of undergraduate
education I had also seen I'm very
interested in sports 1979 ESPN started
college sports exploded in popularity it
used to be a weekend activity it became
an every night thing for many students
and the main sponsors of college sports
were the beer companies and they began
to target college students in the 80s
the spuds Mackenzie campaign was one of
their great successes and so these
things started to come together in the
90s and it seemed to me these large
public research universities that in the
70s had poured billions into research
and chasing chasing the proceed the
prestige of research had neglected
undergrad
education but they still desperately
needed tuition dollars and so what they
were giving their students in many ways
was beer and circus this kind of party
seen much of its surrounding big-time
college sports so I came to write the
book how much of the research money
comes from the taxpayer well that's
interesting I mean very very little I
mean when I started at Indiana
University in 1971 the state legislature
was giving about 70% of the state of the
schools budget for everything including
research and it's true across the
country it was quite high but in the
1970s partly in Revolt to taxpayers did
not like the protests of the 60s but
also I think the rise of Ronald Reagan
who made a bunch of his career against
higher education I mean I was in the
California system in the 60s and saw
them and I think it dropped to the point
where now in Indiana something like the
public universities receive 21% of their
budget from the state legislature
including the research other states it's
in the teens California it's been in the
single-digit so at the very time that
they began to privilege research and
chase after it when I was at Purdue
faculty taught for courses a semester in
the 70s it changed to two courses
faculty were hired and are very much
hired these days to do research not to
teach undergraduates that I've had many
faculty tell me that gets in the way of
their research and you certainly
promoted you're given tenure your salary
is very much pegged to your research I
cannot remember at my school as well as
I've asked in many other schools when a
faculty member received tenure as
outstanding and teaching alone they can
be outstanding in research as well as
outstanding in teaching but teaching
alone people just shake their heads and
say no I can remember that how long have
you taught at Indiana University I 1971
I came there and what on a given any
given semester how much do you teach
well I teach
two courses in a year of my four courses
is a typical load I do a large lecture
class you do an undergraduate class of
25 or so another undergraduate class
around 30 and then a seminar a graduate
seminar
now I've for many years I've taught only
undergraduate courses I felt in the late
seventies when my PhD students weren't
getting jobs when literally was driving
a New York taxi I just felt that this
was immoral to continue with these huge
graduate programs and now my department
has finally slimmed down and cut way
back on this but many other schools many
other English departments other
departments still love their research
prestige and their research imperative
so many faculty try to teach us many
graduate courses as possible to get out
of the undergraduate one so I'm an
exception in this what book is this for
you
this is my fourth book about college
sports although I did three previous
books sound that were academic books
when did you start the college sports
books and why well in 1980 I had a
sabbatical from Indiana University and I
went to Montreal Canada where I'm from
originally
and I was starting to write a book about
Orwell I had a contract and such and the
phone rang and it was an old friend of
mine now it was a sports writer who said
Wilson beard just bought a professional
soccer team and it was a time of the
North American Soccer League with Pele
and at the cosmos and in New York and
such and we got a call my friend said
from this Weekly American soccer
magazine called soccer America they want
somebody to cover this team who can
write in English speak French and know
somebody of something about soccer and
between graduate school at Berkeley and
going to Indiana in 1971 I had spent two
years in France and I had played
semi-professional basketball there and
the town owned the team and the soccer
team was right next door and being a
service
court's ban I became interested in
soccer and I went to games and such and
my friend knew this and so I called up
soccer America and they said well
there's an exhibition game against the
cosmos go cover it file your story if we
don't like it we'll give you kill the--
if we do you're hired
and i got hired and it fulfilled a
childhood dream in some ways he's
painted sports writer and i did that for
a number of years indiana was more than
happy for me to take a leave of absence
because it was when the baby boom had
ended so there was a huge under
enrollment of undergraduates and so any
faculty that would take a leave without
pay was more than appreciated so i did
that for three years although then the
soccer league folded and my wife and i
had young children at that point and I
really miss teaching I missed University
life I think being a sports writer is
for a young person it's not for somebody
I already you know was approaching my
40s and so I went back to universities
but I was still interested in college
sports and I had been in English
literature before that and I decided to
change to American Studies and study
college sports and I also freelanced and
kept up part-time with soccer America
and I began hearing from soccer coaches
about the waste mismanagement sometimes
fraud in athletic departments and I
thought well it's an interesting story
and I asked my athletic department if I
could see their financial books and they
said no and I said wait the Indiana
Public Records Act allows me they said
hire a lawyer
it's your shallow pockets versus our
deep pockets and I asked Illinois I
asked Purdue my alma mater and they
stonewalled everybody Stonewall then the
more they stonewalled I decided there
had to be a great story here and one of
my heroes when I was young was I have
stone the great writer who said Dizzy
stone always said everything you want to
know is on the public record you just
got to know where to find it and he was
a genius at that he would have loved the
database age we live in and so
I did a book about the finances of
college sports called college sports Inc
and that was quite successful and I
decided I would do that full time
essentially for my research did you ever
get to see those records there the
accounting at two Indiana and Purdue I
eventually saw the Indiana records after
the book came out
I've had many reporters call me up and
I've steered them to other records and
the Indianapolis Star looked at the
Purdue ones and most athletic
departments lose money by the way that's
why they want to you know keep that
quiet and such but various newspapers
USA Today over the years has done very
good research on that now you went to
Berkeley and Purdue and now teach at
Indiana how big are those three schools
today oh well Berkeley must be well over
30,000 Indiana is I think Purdue's
probably approaching 30,000 at this now
they were much smaller when I was at
Purdue I believe it was 14,000 something
like that Berkeley was smaller when I
started Indiana it was smaller and I
think that's one of the problems at
these schools that they're just enormous
and you begin as a freshman with these
huge lecture classes it can be very very
difficult for you this book beer and
circus comes at a time as you well know
that you're well-known basketball coach
Bobby Knight was fired when you were at
IU I don't know it well but I know you
must have written about him and must
have been outspoken first do you have
tenure at IU
I do if you did not have tenure could
you say what you've been saying about
all the cynjohn school no I had I should
say I got tenure in 1980 which allowed
me to switch fields in my research and
such and I should say IU has a great
tradition of respecting tenure I mean
it's the school of Alfred Kinsey the
pioneers sex researcher and it's my
understanding that the state legislature
wanted to fire him in the 1950s because
they were so outraged
what he was writing about the president
of IU at that time a man named Herman B
Wells who died recently actually I did
not like Kinsey did not like his work
but said if Indiana University is to be
a real University it has to respect
professor Kenzie's tenure and freedom of
speech and such and that's been true
I've spoken out about college sports for
over 10 years now and have criticized
Indiana University and pointed out when
it lost money and such now I did not
really enter the night controversy to
this year I had commented about him but
it was really this year I was on the
original CN NS I report that exposed him
choking the player Neil Reed and such
and the next day he held a press
conference on ESPN this is in the middle
of March and he denounced everybody who
spoke on that program all that I had
said basically is there's there were two
sets of rules at Indiana University one
for every faculty member and staff
member who had authority over students
and no set of rules for Bob Knight and I
called him the Emperor of Indiana and he
denounced everybody who had been on that
program all the players and me and such
and that was a signal to his fans to you
know send me vilifying emails and such
and this escalated through the spring to
the point where they just they could not
find Neil Reed the player who was Joe
noir and his former assistant coach
named Ron felling who Knight had fired
in December and who allegedly gave the
tape of Reed being choked to CNN and
that was really the smoking gun in this
whole saga but they could find me
because I work for a public institution
and they also discovered on the indiana
website it listed my fall classes and as
every professor it's your name the room
the day of the week
the time you're going to teach and they
downloaded that and said let's invades
perverse classes and such and I saw that
and there were other threats and I went
to my boss and I said I just can't teach
under these
circumstances and now the university
said we'd put a cop in every class and I
said I've been there you know I went to
Berkeley in the 60s I actually was in a
class with a policeman I could tell you
it's very distracting but more to the
point since one of my courses was this
freshman course there could be a
discussion section with a graduate
student young graduate student 25
freshman and one of these lunatics comes
flying through the door and you know I'm
responsible for that
and I said you could put a cop in the
class but say a freshman calls home and
tells her parents there's a cop in my
class I know my daughter was a freshman
in college a number of years ago
and if she had called home I'd be on the
phone so fast to the university that so
they agreed that I should take a leave
and that's what I'm on now now I
planning to go back to teaching in
January at IU for those who never watch
sports and have never heard of Bobby
Knight right what's the controversy ah
the controversy really is how important
is college sports to a university and
throughout this whole thing I stayed on
message as they say in Washington I just
said college sports scandal or a
controversy should never overshadow the
academic purpose of a university I kept
keep seeing saying that in the book and
unfortunately this was a situation where
Bob Knight had become a culture hero in
Indiana in many ways and many people saw
not Indiana University but Bob Knight
University and for the outside world
this was making us look ridiculous and
how long was he there he was there the
same amount of he came the exact same
time I did 29 years ago in 1971 what was
he able to do that you weren't able to
do well he won three national
championships in basketball no but I
mean what was it that he was able to
violate that you were unable to balance
well on the CNN SI thing they showed the
player Neil Reed choking accusing night
of choking him I they showed other
players talking about various incidents
in the
locker room that night had acted very
improperly and I was sitting in a
classroom in Valentine Hall where I work
it was an empty classroom and the CNN
announcer asked me well if you did these
things in this classroom what would
happen to you and I said I'd be
suspended and all Prime by the time I
got back to my office on the fourth
floor there'd be tenure hearings
probably and it's very hard to lose your
tenure but this would be certainly if
the allegations about choking were
proven true I would lose my tenure I
would be fired
and because the videotape showed that
night indeed choked Reid I think that
finally moved the university to in May
to consider firing him and then finally
to imposing some rules upon him and
that's what and apparently he would not
live by these rules called zero
tolerance and a number of weeks ago in
September early September Miles brand
the president fired night but I think
the controversy well night had brought
lots of positives to Indiana University
he had won national championships he had
run clean programs in a very corrupt
sport he had also graduated a majority
of his players now his fans and he say
98 percent but that's by doing the
statistics in a totally aberrant way the
NCAA says lower 60s that's higher than
most other coaches and I guess his fans
saw him as a culture hero that he
represented values he claims to
represent discipline although he's one
of the least discipline persons I've
ever observed and in his behavior
publicly as well as privately and but
they saw him as representing traditional
values and a bringing fame and fortune
to the state of Indiana and such and
they felt this was much more important
than the reputation of Indiana
University as an academic institution or
anything like that I
quite the opposite very deeply uh you
know we were not in the commercial
entertainment business we are in higher
education we should address those
problems unfortunately this became a
huge distraction for the university in
your book beer and circus how did you
organize it and what will people get
well I organized it chronologically in
the sense that I start with the 1970s
and I start with the research imperative
of the university I also discussed the
film Animal House which as a cultural
document is terribly important in that
each generation of students defines
itself differently from the previous one
and the previous ones had been very
politically active and such and in what
I'd call a failure of imagination many
late seventies students embrace the film
Animal House and embrace the kind of
culture of drinking and such that it
glorified so I moved through the 70s and
the 80s and do it chronologically there
is a long section about the research
university and it's eels and also the
rise of beer and circus as a section
called College Light less educationally
filling and then I bring it to the
present and talk about how schools are
marketing beer and circus very
consciously if you remember in the fall
there was a controversy at the
University of Wisconsin where in their
admissions brochures they had shown a
number of students at a football game
and through Photoshop they changed the
race of one of these students to show
diversity I'm not interested in that
question so much as how schools are
using this in their marketing and
certainly to a high school senior in the
state of Wisconsin our surrounding
states they're well aware that Camp
Randall Stadium in Madison the football
stadium is one of the great
alcohol-soaked venues in America so come
to Wisconsin for beer and circus they
didn't show you in this brochure any of
the huge lecture halls that you're gonna
endure or anything like that so I really
feel that schools have taken a horrible
turn when they start using this as their
main marketing tool you say there are
four cultures and
schools collegiate academic vocational
and rebel are those brochures that you
invented or no no there were it's
interesting most sociologists have not
studied undergraduate student life most
academics were academic and we're most
concerned about school and we're not
interested in the other subcultures
particularly the collegiate one which
was the rah-rah party scene and such but
in the late 1950s early 60s a number of
sociologists at Berkeley became very
interested in that in part because
Berkeley really represented all of these
cultures and it was a kind of hotbed of
college activity and so these
sociologists really defined these
cultures and I brought it up to date and
used it collegiate culture who's in that
well it tends to be fraternity and
sorority members students who love
college sports who want their degrees
but are not particularly engaged with
the intellectual aspects of the
university and such you were active in
after Nia to provide I was I was very
collegiate I not only was active I was
president of my fraternity
it wasn't top salon five which later
disappeared through a horrible incident
but there was a couple years after I
graduated I was vice president in the
interpreter Neri council but it was an
age where faculty had enough time to
look at students and in my case see
beyond the crew cut and the fraternity
pin and see somebody who was interested
in books and I had some wonderful
English professors at Purdue the people
who started modern fiction studies and
they prepared me for graduate school and
the hardest graduate school in English
in the country and Berkeley so I
received a wonderful education there Oh
despite the institution in many ways and
it could not be replicated unfortunately
the second category of the cultures is
academic what
they do look and and how many by first
of all how many of the school is we are
in the collegiate group well certainly
these large public universities have
huge contingents I know in my research
at Indiana University I would say about
50% now one of the things that's changed
from when the research was originally
done which at that point it was very
hard to move between cultures I was
fortunate that I could move from
collegiate to academic now I have a
chapter near the end of the book called
student mix-and-match where it's much
easier for students to move certainly
between the collegiate and the
vocational and rebel cultures which
we'll talk about in a minute but and
students can begin in one culture move
to another their next year and so forth
so the lines are breaking down as the
national culture breaks down academic
culture who belongs well future
professors by and large and certainly at
a school like Indiana I'd say about only
about 10 percent of the undergraduates
other schools like swathmore University
of Chicago obviously have much higher
percentages of academically oriented
students one of the problems at large
research universities is the faculty
tends to come out of the academic
culture and academic schools and I have
little sympathy or understanding for the
collegiate subculture there I mean in my
department I can only think of their
many faculty went to Amherst Ivy League
schools and all of this but I only have
one colleague that I can think of who
went to a large public university like I
did he went to LSU and but this is you
know very typical of academic
departments in public universities is in
the Vocational culture well those are
the students who have to work
traditionally you see them at urban
schools people who are working full-time
and have to fit in school in the evening
at odd hours on the weekends and such
and residential campus like Indiana
University in Bloomington does not have
that higher percentage although as
tuition Rises more and more
students have to work part-time to go to
school
Indianapolis at Indianapolis there's a
campus of combined of Purdue and Indiana
called IUPUI that's mainly vocational
students but one of the things in my
research I discovered is that the
athletes are vocational students if
you're on an athletic scholarship you're
on a contract a one-year renewable
contract and you are in very intensive
training programs 30 40 sometimes 50
hours a week and you cannot take courses
in the afternoon because you have
practice and various other things and
you're often tired in fact over the
years I've encountered very few dumb
jocks what I've encountered are
physically and mentally exhausted
athletes who academically underachieve
the same way vocational students
academically underachieved
typically a vocational student will ask
you the first day of class what do I
need to do to get a B in this course and
you know a professor who is an academic
finally wants to hear something like
what will I learn in this course or
something but okay I have sympathy with
vocational students you know they have
very difficult lives and in fact I'd
much rather teach them and the athletes
I have the athletes by the way after
their eligibility is over either through
four years or injury are often wonderful
students because the discipline that
they've learned in athletics they can
apply academics I'd much rather teach
them than my collegiate beer-drinking
students who are never there on Fridays
Monday's are lost Thursday afternoons
are gone and such and they never get
with the academic program so in some
ways I had very much admire the
vocational students the rebel category
well that's a kind of minority these
days of course in the sixties they and
some campuses were dominant and there
are still some schools like Sarah
Lawrence for instance that has a fair
number of politically active
environmentally conscious students often
they're students who are interested in
parts of the academic program I've long
taught a course called 1950s
youth culture an American Studies type
course and part of the curriculum is on
The Beat Generation so I have a fair
number of rebel students in there
although at Indiana University I would
think far less than 10% our rebel
students and these students want to know
all about the beats who were original
rebel students at Columbia in many ways
they invented the modern form Ginsberg
and Kerouac and these students will turn
on to the beat stuff and such but
they'll disappear for other parts of the
course and they've long been in American
higher education they're often by far
the most interesting type students and
but certainly at a campus like Indiana
or these large public research
universities they're often a minority
and tiny minority and they'll drop out
Bloomington has a very large music scene
they'll join that and such but they're
often by far the most interesting type
students what's wrong with someone
paying a place to call the University
money and coming to that University and
loving sports and living sports and
drinking as you say the binge drinking
and all that and getting the grades and
and getting out what's what's wrong
let's talk about the grades let's start
at the back end move forward yes they
can get A's there's been huge grade
inflation I have a chapter called the
faculty student non-aggression pact if
you're paid to do research as a faculty
member you're and that's where the
rewards are there are no rewards in
undergraduate teaching it's taking your
time and you want to get through it as
quickly as possible it's a lot easier to
give a student an A then a B or a C or
god forbid a D or an F you agree you're
inviting lawsuits if you go down that
road even though the student might
deserve it so indeed many students get
high grades and get their degrees and
think they've learned something but I
really question it I've had many seniors
in my classes who really could not read
or write at a college level I've seen
this nationally one of the proposals I
have at the end of the book is before a
student receives a degree from an
accredited university
versity he or she should take the
Graduate Record exam this is the
equivalent it's done by the SAT people
for college seniors who want to go on to
graduate school and they should achieve
a minimum score this is much less
culturally biased than the SAT it's an
excellent exam I took it myself and but
I've said this to college presidents and
administrators and they just roll their
eyes because you know the emperor has no
clothes they know that if they subjected
all their degree candidates to the GRE
many of many of them would not receive
that too great so in that sense schools
are very much shortchanging students I
think you know as far as the drinking
and the rooting for the teams and such
the Harvard School of Public Health has
done wonderful research on student
drinking and they don't divide schools
between schools where students drink and
don't drink I mean the only call Stone
called sober school in America it
probably is bring them young they the
Harvard people talk about high bench
schools and low bench schools and their
characteristics for high bench as well
as my own research and other people are
schools where students take these huge
lecture classes become many become
academically alienated from that whole
process but these schools have huge
college sports programs and students
love them and there's a very large party
scene around it sports bars line the
campuses and there's a kind of nightly
drinking scene for many students as well
as a huge weekend scene low bench
schools tend to be schools where the
students go to class during the week are
not academically alienated but on the
weekend party and my daughter goes to
Rice University so at school a low bench
school that I've observed quite a bit
over the last couple of years and this
students seem attached to their studies
but on the weekends there's no question
they party now the Rice Owls are not a
winning sports tradition for although
they play at the highest level
they have things like beer bike and
various other things
so my ambition actually is very modest I
would like schools to move from high
binge to low bench to start focusing on
undergraduate education start giving
their students a meaningful education
and degree and ratchet down the college
sports programs ratchet down the the
binge drinking I mean binge drinking is
a very serious problem in America that
only gets reported when a student
actually dies but you'd better believe
it continues and one of the horrible
parts of it is from the time I was in
college and even in the 70s women now
drink much more than ever before and one
of the now the role of women in America
has changed I know I have many female
students who drink something called Long
Island iced tea I mean it sounds very
innocuous and such but it is a very
potent drink and so this has become a
kind of national epidemic and schools
just don't want to address it what they
do their lawyers have told the campus
police to move it out of the fraternity
houses move it off campus to avoid legal
liability but they don't care about the
off-campus scene particularly in fact
that's what attracts many students to
their schools I don't mean to beat this
drum but what what's wrong again with
somebody who wants to spend their money
and come to a college and binge drink
and spend their life talking about
sports and if the colleges are letting
them get the grades and there's great
inflation who's to blame and all this
well what's wrong with it
it's a free society I agree if you want
to spend your money that way I just
don't call it higher education because
it's not higher than anything I mean you
know why not encourage these people or
set up a situation where these people
really can't make it in the school I had
fraternity brothers who essentially
binge drunk their way out of Purdue and
you know there's plenty of neighborhood
bars and sports bars where if that's
what you want to do consume your life
drinking and watching sports in fact you
can do it better now than ever before in
our society ok let me just go step
further this is the country that
everybody wants to be like because it
does so well it's fine
successful again why do you want to
change things if we're really the the
Idol of everybody's eye well we're not
the idol in higher education in fact as
a Canadian I'm very aware of the fact
there's no other higher education system
in the world for instance that gives
athletic scholarships that sees itself
as providing minor-league training not
only in basketball and football which
are an historic role in this country but
now in baseball and hockey and any
number of areas for instance I called up
the National Hockey League office a
number of years ago and I said how many
players in the NHL played Canadian
college hockey because a huge number of
Canadians played American college hockey
and play in the NHL and they eventually
found one player who had not gone into
the pro system or the American college
system as a young as an eighteen year
old he had been under sized and it
played a year at the University of
Calgary and then went in the Pro System
but in Europe you want to be a soccer
player you don't go to university
aiyoo it's a whole different system and
so I don't think they want that for one
thing I spent the summer in Montreal to
get away from the whole night thing and
in Quebec the system is you go three
years to high school two years to junior
college and three years to university
and as a result because everybody goes
to junior college I it doesn't have the
stigma it has in this country it
corrects the remedial problems that
universities are burdened with because
the high schools are turning up people
who can't read or write
in many at a decent level and then it
also gives terminal degrees and if you
want to go to university you're much
better prepared but nowhere in the
university system are they giving
athletic scholarships and such now the
UN does these studies of the literacy
and numeracy level of populations and
such Canada comes first the United
States is something like 13th so the
rest of the world wants to imitate lots
of American things but it does not want
to imitate I don't see any country
making a move to institute athletic
scholarships big-time college sports and
universities
and the panoply of problems that come
with them again going back to your
position is it feel lonely out there it
does certainly at Indiana University it
felt very lonely criticizing Bob Knight
but your your fellow professors seem to
like the research money ah yeah
fortunately my own university is still
up so obsessed with Bob Knight that they
haven't really focused on my book yeah I
have started to get heat from people who
very much condemned what I'm saying and
say don't I realize that this is the
triumph of American higher education and
such and in my proposals I say yes keep
the research for well really turn it
into the European model more of
Institute's if private corporations want
to fund Institute's and such but
separate it from undergraduate education
don't burden undergraduate education
with it as it's now done who funded your
research ah my publisher Henry Holt I
applied for grants over the years and
nobody wanted to give grants to somebody
investigating college sports or
investigating these problems and
essentially the advances from my
publisher funded my research so I thank
Henry Holt for that and how did you do
your research I did it a number of ways
for this book I read deeply in the
history of higher education as well as
college sports I also read a lot of the
sociology I worked with some people and
designed my own survey and I went to a
great number of schools I handed it out
in classes I went to places like student
unions and handed it out and then
because my wife is a computer whiz I put
it up on the web and after it was all
over I received over nineteen hundred
responses and I found students were
quite wonderful students really are
aware of what's going on and if an adult
approaches them and in a neutral way
wants to talk to them say I'm not going
to use your name this is a survey and
such I they will open up I mean it seems
to me the highlight of the book are the
student comments they had stories in
there that were just brilliant
and I remember I have a section about
pens about spring break and a student of
Penn State had written in the comment
section on my web survey the question
was after you leave the school what will
you remember most about it and or what
will you remember most about your time
here and he talked about Spring Break
and really showed me that here was a
very moveable concept for college
students they're talking about their
collegiate subculture that moves away
but he said what he would remember most
was the spring breaks and being a
different motels and hotels in Florida
and in Texas and going out on the
balcony and generally you go out on a
hotel balcony it's deserted but you'd go
out at spring break and it was just
filled with screaming college students
and that was his most vivid memory of
college and I thought you know that that
was such a memorable comment you know
you couldn't begin to get them if you
didn't listen to the students I have
something that just because it's in the
Washington area I wanted to read to you
and and have you put it in context she'd
probably don't even know about this this
is an important notice the University of
Maryland and this was on the windshield
of people in the parking lots it says
please remind faculty no it actually was
given that I think it was given to the
students Beverly please remind faculty
that on September the 28th the campus
will be hosting the Florida State game
and parking will be an important issue
for students attending campus we are
warning faculty who have a class at 3
p.m. or later of this issue so they can
make alternate arrangements and include
it in the fall syllabi and the warning
is get your get your vehicles out of the
parking lots at 3 o'clock on a Thursday
afternoon and this goes with this letter
dear permit holder as you may already
know on Thursday September the 28th at 8
p.m. the University of Maryland football
team will play Florida State at Byrd
Stadium this Atlantic Coast Conference
game will be televised by ESPN Thursday
night they had some of these professors
had to cancel class right because there
was no place to park I just ask you how
often does this go on and why it goes on
increasingly often its athletic
departments love the TV dollars Maryland
historically has lost money on college
sports and it's chasing every dollar at
confined and ESPN has to fill up 24
hours of sports it when it started it
took college basketball from a weekend
activity and put it on in every night
activity in fact this year for the first
time
there's Sunday night college basketball
the ACC has gone to Sunday night you'll
probably see Maryland on there but this
idea of thirst it was Friday football
then Thursday football within the decade
you will see Monday Tuesday Wednesday
yeah football and of course you're gonna
have at Maryland for the Florida State
game huge numbers of fans Florida State
being a winning being a national
champion attracts huge numbers of fans
and indeed professors will have to call
off classes students won't be there some
Maryland students because it partly a
vocational school where people commute
from Washington just won't go that day
other students will start the parties
early because there's a big fraternity
sorority system there but it's really a
perfect example of beer and circus well
you did your survey did you put it there
the results back on the web
unfortunately I didn't because Knights
fans discovered the survey and so
trashed it that I took it down but I
should hopefully if all this will die
down and mr. Knight will move on I'll
put it back on the way have you ever met
him that way no in 29 years I never met
him but it's not a story about Bob
Knight and me it's really a story about
big-time college sports I realized but I
wanted to know what it feels like I mean
you're talking about you know hiding up
in Canada and you're on a sabbatical
list this year and all that is is it all
worth it but you know the best
description of what it feels like I
could never figure it out for myself and
I had lunch this summer with a young
faculty member who had come to Indiana
from another school that was a very open
school and he said you know coming to
the school was like coming into a
dysfunctional family at the head of the
family was Bob Knight you know this very
abusive person
although he either people in the family
psalm is a breadwinner because he had
brought fame and fortune to Indiana
University and normally rational people
would make excuses for his behavior and
if he said it was just this weirdest
thing and I said to him well what was
what's my role in this whole thing and
he said you're the crazy uncle who goes
around mumbling the truth but nobody
wants to listen and so I when I think
about it that was really the role and
the isolation and such and I know it
became very hard for my wife who's a
very private person and certainly this
spring at the height of the controversy
on this and before going to Montreal she
stopped using her credit card because
people would see the name Sperber and
they would say are you related to
Maurice barber and Danny if they were
night fans they would yell at her now
fortunately many people would say you
know I really respect what your
husband's doing and such but she just
felt she didn't need that when she's
going to buy the groceries at Kroger's
and such and other things so in that
sense it was very isolating but college
towns can become that way what do you
think is at work here I mean you're just
one person saying the guy oughtta go or
whatever why do they just won't they
just ignore you why do they get so bent
out of shape yeah I never understood
that and the same with my criticisms of
college sports I mean they're huge and
fast and they've got this huge machine
and I'm like the guy in front of the
tank and Tina moons square you know it's
they they got the tank and I've just got
the peashooter of the book and so I I
guess I've never understood why it
bothers them so much I think there's
something in the sports mentality I'm
particularly Bob Knight was called the
general and he is a perfectionist
the idea that you're either on the team
if you work for a university or you're
opposed to it and have to be silenced I
think many faculty did not speak up
because they see Indiana University as a
team and it certainly wasn't in their
interest to speak up and so in that way
the sports mentality laps over and my
first book was college sports thankful
Department versus the University I'm
thinking of doing a book called college
sports mega Inc the athletic department
is the university because increasingly
that kind of corporate mentality is
taking over the university I know
President brand wrote in the paper when
I took when my taking a leave because of
the threats to my teaching became public
and defending my freedom of speech but
he wrote that many many alumni had
written him and said how can you let
this guy Sperber speak up if he worked
for my corporation you better believe
he'd be quiet or he'd be out the door so
in that sense it really poses very
interesting problems about freedom of
speech and freedom of research and where
the American University is going and I'm
unfortunately it is increasingly going
to this corporate model would you do
this again the book all this criticism
and take on a Bobby Knight in the sports
world okay
okay I people ask me that all the time
and I think you don't live your life
that way and in the sense that at each
step at each crossroads it seemed to me
the logical thing to do one of the
reasons I spoke up this year is in
January
ESPN asked me to be on a program about
Bobby Bowden the Florida State coach in
the hour before the championship game
between Florida State and Virginia Tech
and I had some negative things to say
about him as well as some positive and
received lots of nasty email from
Florida State people but then CNN si
comes along and says we want you to
speak up about Bob Knight it's or could
just comment you were not going to tell
you what to say just comment and it
seemed to me because I'm a well-known
critic of college sports and it's spoken
about Bobby Bowden I couldn't take a
pass about Bobby Knight because he's the
coach at my school it just did not so at
that point so that's why I chose to do
that and so I never think would I do it
again I guess cuz I can't go back in the
time machine and change it now if you
had it to do over again would you join a
fraternity based on what you know today
sure because the alternative at Purdue
was living in these very horrible dorms
and
and the fraternity was a much more human
experience some of those people of our
lifelong friends and some are lifelong
enemies so ya know I mean again in in
retrospect that was the choice at that
time in the same way when I graduated
from Purdue I had a choice of going to
law school or the University of
California Berkeley in English I chose
English I have never regretted that for
a minute of my life but knowing what you
know now and you've written about these
big schools and all the sports would you
go back to a perdu again yes I would I
deeply believe in public education I
mean I've been asked a lot would I go to
a private university because I talked
about in the book how they are doing by
and large a much better job of
undergraduate education and pretty
transform me it changed my life the
University of California Berkeley
changed me even more my wife grew up in
a poor family in Oakland California and
went to Berkeley it was free then by the
way and it was free for me so I really
deeply believe in public education the
best thing for me at Indiana University
in 29 years are the students and you get
students from small rural communities in
Indiana from large cities who don't know
how smart they are and are lost and you
can I've really felt that I've made an
impact in their lives one of the few
positive things with this whole night
business is I received lots of emails
from former students who said I just
want to tell you I really appreciate it
you're taking time when you were a
teacher teaching me and such and so yeah
no I absolutely believe in public
education and for me to leave it I would
make no sense what do you think of the
honors programs at schools well they
were the key to proving how bad
undergraduate education is I mean it was
sort of I was I did my research I truly
believed it was in terrible shape but
how can you prove it because you I'd
call up my universities and they I'd ask
them about an undergraduate education
and they would say oh it's great it's
fabulous and it happened I was in DC and
I was at the crown bookstore on Dupont
Circle and they have a very good
education
section because of all the associations
across the street and I saw this book
Peterson's guide to honors programs and
what it does is it it reproduces their
literature basically and I started
reading it and I got out of my pen and I
started underlining and I sat on one of
those stools and a clerk came over to me
and said sir you are gonna buy that book
aren't you and I said not only am I
gonna buy that book I would pay ten
times your face your list price for that
book because it was the key that opened
the door in their own words Maryland for
instance they say come to our Honors
Program they're competing against
private schools for those students and
in it you'll take small classes taught
by full faculty as opposed to regular
Maryland students are gonna take huge
lecture classes often taught by graduate
students and all of this so in their own
words I was able to prove the neglect of
undergraduate education I remember the
University of Oregon said our Honors
Program will teach you such fundamental
skills as reading and writing and I
thought wait a second
you mean the regular classes won't teach
those fundamental skills I guess that's
what they're saying that's in their own
words so in that sense the honors
programs helped me now what I actually
think about them as a strong advocate of
public universities I have always
refused to teach in the Honors Program
at Indiana that seems to me a kind of
easy way out a lot of faculty love it
because they can actually do some of
their research with the honors students
but it's a much greater challenge to me
to teach regular undergraduates as I was
at Purdue Purdue didn't have an Honors
Program at that point and nor did most
schools and you know just I don't feel
they belong in public universities I
think it's a way of schools avoiding
their problems with undergraduate
education it's maybe not be a fair
question but do your books sell they do
I seem to there seems to be an audience
for that and I notice on amazon.com this
books been in triple digits which is
quite good and I did a book about the
history of Notre Dame football that's
old exceptionally well and yeah they so
quickly in your research and you say he
went to 40 different schools in your
research right who's who which
university was the most friendly and
said come on in you're gonna look at
everything
ah actually Stanford University wasn't
it's a private school Notre Dame was
historically people have a terrific
misconception about a Notre Dame that
they're hostile to the outside world
quite the opposite they are totally
professional they let me go wherever I
want and talk to whoever I wanted no
holds barred who is the least friendly
ah probably well it's hard to say there
are schools that just said don't come
here Syracuse University yeah was not
interested in me going there I did I had
some web surveys I said don't come they
said no they didn't say don't come they
just from there you know we're very busy
you know we're doing our own research on
these topics and you know we'll get back
to you a sort of thing in the brief time
we have left that how much of this do
you blame on somebody like CBS and an 11
year contract with the National
Collegiate Athletic Association and how
much is it worth six billion not six
million six billion dollars I blame a
lot well they're doing you know they're
in the TV business
I blame universities and the NCAA for
taking the money in the sense and not
admitting this is not a that's not six
billion as a contribution to higher
education that's payment for a product
and the product the schools have to turn
out is in this case college basketball
played at the highest possible level
which means putting players in these
very intensive training programs making
it difficult for them to get a
meaningful education and also pretending
the NCAA in schools have this whole
propaganda machine about student
athletes and they show you that thing at
halftime and all of that and pretending
that this is a wonderful system the six
billion
helps higher education enormous ly what
it does is it distorts public opinion
I've I do a certain amount of speaking
at Kiwanis Clubs and Rotary clubs and
such and meet ordinary people and they
truly they see those numbers and the
bold numbers and they truly believe that
the money from college sports funds
other parts of the universities the Bob
night fans constantly said don't I
realize my salary as an English
professor is paid by the athletic
department from its profits that is
totally false so in a sense it hurts the
universities in all kinds of ways how
many of these coaches make a million
dollars a year oh gee at this point I'd
say about 40 are approaching them in
basketball and football pays for that
essentially the University now part of
it is the deals with the shoe contracts
and such but Nike does not pay a coach
because they love some middle-aged fat
coach they want that team to win and the
Nike swoosh is very visible on TV they
want fans to look in and see the players
are wearing their product so when they
pay a coach hundreds of thousands of
dollars essentially that's money that
should go to the school but doesn't and
goes to the coach so it's a very
distorted system but unfortunately
increasing numbers of faculty look at
that and say hey I should be an
entrepreneur like the coach will we see
you back in the Indiana University
English classroom I'm planning to be
back in January although the problem is
the night thing doesn't seem to end the
fans don't give up there you look at
their web sites and there's this fantasy
that the trustees are gonna firebrand or
a judge will intervene and do it and
bring Bob Knight back and until they
actually give up I believe until he is
coaching at another school I you cannot
move past them who you have a champion
out there now somebody in public
education who is leading to change
things well there's a group of faculty
that's organized that I'm a member of
called naff card
National Alliance for collegiate
athletic reform that has a number of
prominent faculty members across the
country that we're gonna we spoke at the
night Commission hearings on October
18th in Washington and you know there
that's funded by the knight-ridder
Foundation and they investigated college
sports 10 years ago father Hesburgh of
Notre Dame and Bill Friday Chancellor of
the Carroll North Carolina system our
co-chairs
and they're interested in our ideas now
whether it can have an effect or not
remains to be seen
our guest has been Mary Sperber and he
is the author of this book beer and
circus how big-time college sports is
crippling undergraduate education thank
you very much thank you beer and circus
is published by Henry Holton company on
the web at Henry Holt com
next week on encore booknotes Phillip
Tubman who looks at space espionage in
secret Empire for